salut aujourd'hui je vais vous raconter
une petite anecdote sur quelqu'un que
vous connaissez bien et pourtant quand
je veux dire son nom ça va pas vous
parler il s'agit de charles d'auxonne
pense pas que ça vous dit ce grand chose
en 1862 un jour pour s'occuper il
raconte à 3 frangine trois soeurs ni
histoire de ouf
une histoire qu'il invente dans son
histoire il emmène la protagoniste dans
un terrier de lapin il l'a fait tomber
dans un trou et à ce moment là il n'a
aucune idée de ce qui va arriver à la
fille ça par contre ça doit vous
rappeler quelque chose est sûre les
trois soeurs à qui raconter cette
histoire il était amoureux de l'une
d'entre elles alors pour essayer de
marquer des points et lui faire plaisir
il a appelé son héroïne comme la fille
qu'il aimait c'est-à-dire alice et cette
fameuse alice la vraie celle qui
existait vraiment à lui a demandé de
décrire l'histoire sur une feuille
parce qu'elle avait bien aimé le début
et donc il a écrit cette histoire pour
cette fille là qu'il est mais c'est
ainsi que d'auxonne a écrit alice au
pays des merveilles qui est l'un de mes
romans préférés
il a écrit sous le pseudonyme de lewis
carroll qui n'est pas du tout son volant
la fille en question celle qui existe
s'appelle alice liddell dans la suite de
l'histoire qui a été publié en 1871 de
l'autre côté du miroir
lewis carroll a caché un acrostiche un
acrostiche sais tu prends la première
lettre de chaque mot et sa forme un
nouveau mot même une phrase par exemple
fabien à biarritz ça ferait f ab saffré
fab
tu vois l'idée est bien la version
originale de l'autre côté du miroir
c'est à dire la version en anglais il ya
un endroit où il ya un acrostiche et si
on prend les premières lettres de chaque
mot on retrouve alice plaisance lidl qui
était le nom complet de la vraie alice
j'espère que cette petite anecdote
littéraire vous aura plu si c'est le cas
n'oubliez pas de cliquer là en ce moment
on est sur une vidéo tous les deux jours
jusqu'au 30 août
vous pouvez aussi vous abonner pour pas
les rater et puis moi je vous dis belles
vacances si vous êtes en vacances et
après demain
[Musique]